This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Over the course of our lives, we all accrue a ledger of the wrongs done to us. For some of us, that ledger is long and detailed. We find ourselves pouring over the pages again and again, accounting for each betrayal, tallying every injustice, adding up the petty cruelties. We sit with these wrongs done to us and as time slides by our anger festers instead of fading away. This week on Hidden Brain we begin a series on forgiveness and apologies. We'll consider why holding a grudge can feel bad and good at the same time.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在我们的一生中，我们都积累了一本关于他人对我们所做错事的账本。对我们中的一些人来说，这本账本既冗长又详尽。我们发现自己一遍又一遍地翻阅这些页面，清算每一次背叛，记录每一项不公，累积每一件琐碎的残忍。我们沉浸在这些受到的伤害中，随着时间的流逝，我们的愤怒非但没有消退，反而愈演愈烈。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将开启一个关于宽恕与道歉的系列节目。我们将探讨为什么怀恨在心既让人感觉糟糕，又同时让人感觉良好。
And we look at why the process of forgiveness can sometimes be a long struggle between head and heart. This journey has its own twists and turns and there can be surprises. There can be times of incredible, effortful intentionality that feel almost fruitless. But there are other times where that persistence can all of a sudden be met with like an aha revelation, a gift. Granting forgiveness for the wrongs done to us is one of the hardest things human beings can do. At Hope College in Michigan, psychologists Charlotte Whitfleet studies the psychological barriers
我们还将探讨为什么宽恕的过程有时是理智与情感之间的一场漫长斗争。这段旅程有其曲折，也可能会有惊喜。有时会有令人难以置信的、费力的刻意尝试，却感觉几乎毫无成果。但也有其他时候，那种坚持会突然迎来一种顿悟，一份礼物。给予他人宽恕是人类能做的最困难的事情之一。在密歇根州的霍普学院，心理学家夏洛特·威特弗利特研究了宽恕的心理障碍
and effects of forgiveness. She and others have examined why forgiveness is hard and the transformative effects of forgiveness on both victims and transgressors. Shout it with, Fleet, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's a joy to be with you. Shout it, you're a researcher, but you also spend a lot of time in clinical settings,
以及宽恕的影响。她和其他人研究了为什么宽恕如此困难，以及宽恕对受害者和加害者双方的变革性影响。威特弗利特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴能和你在一起。威特弗利特，你是一位研究员，但你也花了很多时间在临床环境中，
working with patients. What kind of hurts and traumas do people tell you that they are carrying around? It's so rare that someone has come into a clinical setting and not had some sort of deep interpersonal pain that felt unfair or unjust to them. There are all sorts of betrayals. There are betrayals from childhood, betrayals in friendship, in families, in romantic relationships, in fidelities, having your reputation maligned. All sorts of hurts show up. And some of us carry these hurts around for years, even decades, right? Oh, yes. That's the powerful thing about memory. Something that happened in the past can
与病人一起工作。人们告诉你他们背负着什么样的伤害和创伤？很少有人走进临床环境时，没有某种深层的人际痛苦，让他们觉得不公平或不公正。各种各样的背叛都有。有童年的背叛，友谊中的背叛，家庭中的背叛，恋爱关系中的背叛，不忠，名誉受损。各种各样的伤害都会出现。我们中的一些人背负着这些伤害多年，甚至几十年，对吧？哦，是的。这就是记忆的强大之处。过去发生的事情可以
be currently embodied. Something that happens this week can activate powerfully painful memories of something that happened 30 years ago. Before we talk about the science of forgiveness and the effects of forgiveness, Charlotte, I want to talk a moment about the barriers to forgiveness. the effects of forgiveness, Charlotte, I want to talk a moment about the barriers to forgiveness. Why forgiveness can be so hard? I want to play your clip from the television show Frazier, where the title character Frazier Crane is a radio host and psychotherapist, and he's trying to convince his father to bury the hatchet with an old friend who's in the hospital.
在当下被具体化。本周发生的事情可以有力地激活30年前发生的痛苦记忆。在我们讨论宽恕的科学和宽恕的影响之前，夏洛特，我想谈谈宽恕的障碍。为什么宽恕会如此困难？我想播放一段电视节目《欢乐一家亲》的片段，主角弗雷泽·克雷恩是一位电台主持人和心理治疗师，他正试图说服他的父亲与一位在医院的老朋友冰释前嫌。
Dad, we're talking about a few minutes out of your life. Just just long enough to sit there and have a little chat with a very sick man. I don't see why that's so impossible for you. Now, come on. Believe me, you'll be glad you did. All right, listen, sonny boy. That sanctimonious tone may wow them on the radio,
爸爸，我们谈论的是你生命中几分钟的时间。只要坐下来和那个病得很重的人聊一会儿就行了。我不明白这对你来说为什么那么不可能。来吧，相信我，你会为你这么做而感到高兴的。好吧，听着，小伙子。那种道貌岸然的语气也许在电台上能唬住人，
but it doesn't cut any ice with me. When I say no, that's just what I mean. I'm not sitting and chatting with Arty Walsh. You know, many of us have had the experience of feeling like Frasier Crane's father there are Charlotte. It doesn't feel enjoyable to hold a grudge to remember the times that we've been hurt, but we also find it very difficult to let go of our hurts and grudges. And you and others have studied why it is this happens.
但对我来说一点用都没有。我说不，就是那个意思。我不会坐下来和阿蒂·沃尔什聊天。你知道，我们很多人都有过像弗雷泽·克雷恩父亲那样的经历，夏洛特。怀恨在心、记住我们受伤害的时刻并不让人愉快，但我们也发现很难放下我们的伤害和怨恨。你和其他人研究了为什么会发生这种情况。
So what do you find? So often I think we seek vindication. And one of the things that we found early on was that when people were thinking about the offense, nursing a grudge took the edge off their sadness. And it actually led them to feel a greater sense of perceived control. And a little less bad. Although overall, they still had the same high levels of anger. Can you talk for a moment, how for many people, letting go of a grudge doesn't even seem
那么你发现了什么？我常认为我们寻求的是平反。我们早期发现的一件事是，当人们思考冒犯行为时，怀恨在心减轻了他们的悲伤。它实际上让他们感到一种更大的感知控制感。感觉稍微没那么糟糕了。尽管总的来说，他们仍然有同样高水平的愤怒。你能谈谈为什么对许多人来说，放下怨恨甚至看起来
like it's possible. They don't even realize that they actually have a choice. I think that our emotions are so powerful and when we're distressed and we see so clearly what is so very wrong, we aren't in a mode of thinking flexibly. We don't always go to the place of saying we can tell the truth about how wrong it is and we can tell the truth about the humanity of the other person. Those things can be really a big stretch for us when we are deeply distressed and acutely aware of how wrong the injustice is.
都不可能吗？他们甚至没有意识到自己其实是有选择的。我认为我们的情绪非常强大，当我们感到痛苦并如此清晰地看到什么是如此错误时，我们并没有处于灵活思考的模式。我们并不总是会说，我们可以说出它是多么错误的事实，也可以说出关于对方人性的事实。当我们深陷痛苦并敏锐地意识到不公正有多严重时，这些事情对我们来说可能真的是一个巨大的挑战。
You mentioned something a second ago about the role that our emotions are playing. You and others have studied how grudges produce anger, but also in some ways how anger then, in turn, feeds a grudge. Can you talk about this almost symbiotic relationship between the hurts we carry, the grudges we hold, and the emotion of anger? Yeah, so anger is something that we experience subjectively, but we also experience it in a very embodied kind of way. And it can put us in a place of almost inflexibility
你刚才提到了情绪所扮演的角色。你和其他人研究了怨恨如何产生愤怒，但在某种程度上，愤怒又是如何反过来滋养怨恨的。你能谈谈我们背负的伤害、我们怀有的怨恨和愤怒情绪之间这种近乎共生的关系吗？是的，愤怒是我们主观体验的东西，但我们也以一种非常具体的方式体验它。它能让我们处于一种近乎僵化的状态，
where we are on the lookout for evidence that we're right and that we have reason to be angry. We can be on the lookout for clues that the person is really as bad as we feel like they are based on the behavior. We can tell the story of what happened in such a way that it really conveys our powerful emotions, almost amping up the adjectives and adverbs that communicate the force of our emotions, but that can also amp up the contempt and condemnation that we experience. And those things sort of solidify the anger, solidify the narrative, and solidify that place of emotional inflexibility.
我们一直在寻找证据证明我们是对的，我们有理由生气。我们可以寻找线索，证明那个人确实像我们根据其行为所感觉到的那样糟糕。我们可以讲述发生的事情，以一种真正传达我们强烈情绪的方式，几乎夸大了形容词和副词来传达我们情绪的力量，但这也会加剧我们所经历的蔑视和谴责。这些东西巩固了愤怒，巩固了叙事，并巩固了那种情绪僵化的状态。
Even when we encounter things that might help us get out of that loop, we're inclined to dismiss them and instead tell the story in a way that supports our remaining in that I want to talk about one last barrier to forgiveness. Sometimes I think we believe that we can ask people to forgive in the absence of accountability, in the absence of what you might call psychological safety. Some years ago we did an episode on a forgiveness ceremony in a war-torn country, this was Sierra Leone, where perpetrators would confess that crimes over a bonfire and victims were expected to immediately forgive them. They gave me a knife to kill his father,
即使我们遇到可能帮助我们走出那个循环的事情，我们也倾向于忽视它们，反而以一种支持我们继续保持这种状态的方式讲述故事。我想谈谈宽恕的最后一个障碍。有时我认为我们相信可以在缺乏问责、缺乏你所说的心理安全的情况下要求人们宽恕。几年前，我们做了一期关于一个饱受战争蹂躏的国家——塞拉利昂的宽恕仪式的节目，那里的加害者会在篝火旁承认罪行，而受害者被要求立即宽恕他们。他们给了我一把刀去杀他的父亲，
but what I did was not my choice. Well, Malakia, please forgive me. I'm on gun djump there. I have accepted it, and I have agreed to forgive him. But when the researcher, Androla Dubé, later measured the effectiveness of the technique on psychological well-being, here is what she found. This process of talking about the past is actually painful and personally difficult for people as manifest in worsened
但我所做的不是我的选择。好吧，马拉基亚，请原谅我。我接受了，我同意原谅他。但是当研究员安德罗拉·杜贝后来测量该技术对心理健康的有效性时，她发现了这一点。这种谈论过去的过程实际上对人们来说是痛苦且个人困难的，表现为
psychological well-being in these communities. So we have three different measures that we look at, an anxiety, post-traumatic stress disorder, and depression. And we find that all three outcomes are actually worse in the communities that have gone through this process. And we think this is consistent with the idea that going through these memories of war in a short, intense fashion can actually reopen
这些社区的心理健康状况恶化。所以我们有三个不同的衡量指标，焦虑、创伤后应激障碍和抑郁。我们发现，经历过这个过程的社区中，所有这三个结果实际上都更糟。我们认为这与以下观点一致：以一种简短、强烈的方式回顾这些战争记忆实际上可能会重新打开
some old wounds. So, Shadot, can you talk about this idea that trying to force forgiveness, especially in maybe this short, intense way, without perhaps proper accountability, that in some ways it could backfire on our ability to be forgiving. Yes, when we have horrifying hurts, traumas, to put people in a position where they're expected to confront that pain and open it up on someone else's terms, but without the sort of time to process them
一些旧伤。所以，夏洛特，你能谈谈这个观点吗：试图强迫宽恕，特别是在这种可能缺乏适当问责的简短、强烈的方式下，在某种程度上可能会适得其反，影响我们宽恕的能力。是的，当我们有可怕的伤害、创伤时，让人们处于一种被期望面对那种痛苦并按照别人的条件打开它的境地，但却没有时间去处理它们，
as well as without the sense of agency that I'm deciding to do this. This is a choice of mine and I'm committing to it. We often have to hit the pause button say, first we need to care about safety. I mean physical safety, emotional safety, psychological safety, sexual safety, spiritual safety. If we haven't assured safety and if we don't have plans in place for accountability that halts the harms, we can actually add deep hurt to that existing hurt and put people at greater risk. When we come back, how grudges and forgiveness affect our bodies and our minds. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychology is Charlotte Whitfleet studies the barriers, pathways and effects of forgiveness.
也没有那种“我决定这样做”的代理感。这是我的选择，我致力于此。我们通常必须按下暂停键，说：首先我们需要关心安全。我是指身体安全、情感安全、心理安全、性安全、精神安全。如果我们没有确保安全，如果我们没有制定问责计划来制止伤害，我们实际上可能会在现有的伤害之上增加深层的伤害，并将人们置于更大的风险之中。稍后回来，怨恨和宽恕如何影响我们的身体和思想。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家夏洛特·威特弗利特研究了宽恕的障碍、途径和影响。
Many of us find that the body is not a human being. It is a human being. It is a human being. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychology is Charlotte Whitfleet studies the barriers, pathways, and effects of forgiveness. Many of us find that giving up hurts can be painful. We sometimes go to great lengths to nurture grudges and to keep the embers of our anger glowing. Grudges can consume our minds, but increasingly, researchers are also discovering that they can have measurable
我们许多人发现身体不是一个人。它是一个人。它是一个人。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家夏洛特·威特弗利特研究了宽恕的障碍、途径和影响。我们许多人发现放弃伤害可能是痛苦的。我们有时会不遗余力地滋养怨恨，让愤怒的余烬持续燃烧。怨恨会消耗我们的思想，但研究人员也越来越多地发现，它们会对我们的身体产生可测量的
effects on our bodies. Charlotte has brought volunteers into the lab and asked them to ruminate on harms done to them. The results are striking. When we ask people to come into the lab and relive these real life hurts that they've experienced. It allows us to see how their bodies react. And we have examined their cardiovascular responses by looking at their heart rates and their blood pressure. We've also looked at a measure called heart rate variability, which is an index of the
影响。夏洛特把志愿者带进实验室，让他们反思自己受到的伤害。结果令人震惊。当我们要求人们来到实验室，重温他们经历过的这些现实生活中的伤害时。这让我们能够看到他们的身体是如何反应的。我们通过观察他们的心率和血压来检查了他们的心血管反应。我们还观察了一种称为心率变异性的指标，它是
parasympathetic or the calming regulatory mechanisms that connect the brain and the heart. And another thing that we've looked at is sweat as well as different facial muscles that are important for emotion. And what do you find happens to people's heart rates and blood pressure and their facial muscles and their sweating? What happens when they ruminate on past herts and grudges? When people come into the lab and they are ruminating about real life herts, their heart rates escalate,
连接大脑和心脏的副交感神经或镇静调节机制的指数。我们观察的另一件事是汗水以及对情绪很重要的不同面部肌肉。你发现人们的心率、血压、面部肌肉和出汗情况发生了什么变化？当他们反思过去的伤害和怨恨时会发生什么？当人们来到实验室并反思现实生活中的伤害时，他们的心率会升高，
their blood pressure surges, and there's an important measure of the regulation of the heart that plummets when people are ruminating. At the same time, their faces are showing furrowing of the brow as well as tension underneath the eye. And all of us in some ways have experienced what you're just describing. We might not have observed these markers as carefully, but all of us I think can remember times when we are lying in bed at night, maybe one o'clock in the morning, two o'clock in the morning, and we remember something hurtful that's happened.
他们的血压会飙升，当人们反思时，心脏调节的一个重要指标会骤降。与此同时，他们的脸上表现出皱眉以及眼睛下方的紧张。我们所有人在某种程度上都经历过你刚才描述的情况。我们可能没有那么仔细地观察这些标记，但我认为我们所有人都能记得在深夜躺在床上，也许是凌晨一点、两点的时候，我们想起了一些发生过的伤人的事情。
And we experienced a stress response in some ways to the memories of past hurt. Yes, have you ever had it where even your chest hurt? Yeah, that's sinking feeling. Sometimes that corresponds to this decrease in vagal tone, which makes it harder to be flexibly toggling out of that ruminative mode. So you do these studies that measure in some ways the effects of rumination on past hurts, but then you also ask some people in these experiments to try and exercise forgiveness. What are the instructions you give them to accomplish this, and what do you find, what do your measures show? One of the prompts that we've used in a lot of our studies is meant to invite a compassionate
我们以某种方式对过去的伤害记忆产生了压力反应。是的，你有没有过甚至胸口都痛的时候？是的，那种下沉的感觉。有时这对应于迷走神经张力的降低，这使得更难灵活地切换出那种反刍模式。所以你做了这些测量反刍对过去伤害影响的研究，但你在这些实验中也要求一些人尝试练习宽恕。你给他们什么指令来完成这个，你发现了什么，你的测量结果显示了什么？我们在许多研究中使用的一个提示旨在邀请一种富有同情心的
way of re-opraising their response to the offender. So we ask people to remember that this person who offended them is a human being and to focus on the humanity of this person. We also ask them to think about the wrongdoing as evidence that things aren't right, that the person needs to experience some sort of learning or growth or change or transformation and that they're in a unique position to be able to see some way in which that person may need to be able to grow or improve, and then find even a small way to genuinely wish that person well towards that good
方式来重新评估他们对冒犯者的反应。所以我们要求人们记住这个冒犯他们的人也是一个人，并专注于这个人的仁慈。我们还要求他们把不当行为视为事情不对劲的证据，即那个人需要经历某种学习、成长、改变或转变，而他们处于一个独特的位置，能够看到那个人可能需要成长或改进的某种方式，然后找到哪怕是一个小小的、真诚地祝愿那个人走向那个美好
future. And when you ask people to do this, do you also continue to measure their physiological markers the ones that you talked about before? Yes. And what do you find? Physiologically, their bodies are showing less of a stress response, so their heart rate doesn't escalate as much. Their blood pressure doesn't escalate as much.
未来的方式。当你要求人们这样做时，你是否也继续测量你之前谈到的生理指标？是的。你发现了什么？在生理上，他们的身体表现出的压力反应较少，所以他们的心率没有升高那么多。他们的血压没有升高那么多。
Their sweat levels are closer to baseline. Their heart rate variability is more like the relaxation baseline condition. So, even though they're still thinking about that same offender and the specific offense that is hurtful, they are able to maintain more of a regulated, calm sort of embodied response. So someone who listens to this and says, all right, you know, I want to tweak my heart rate and blood pressure and parasympathetic nervous system and get those things working in a way that's good for me. And okay, what Shadid Wittfleet is telling me is that if I forgive, I get all of these physical benefits. You have, however, argued that some of these benefits might be better understood
他们的出汗水平更接近基线。他们的心率变异性更像放松基线条件。所以，即使他们仍然在思考同一个冒犯者和那个伤人的具体冒犯，他们也能够保持一种更受调节、更平静的体现反应。所以有人听了这些说，好吧，你知道，我想调整我的心率、血压和副交感神经系统，让这些东西以对我有利的方式工作。好吧，夏洛特·威特弗利特告诉我，如果我宽恕，我就能得到所有这些身体上的好处。然而，你认为这些好处可能被更好地理解为
as side effects of forgiveness rather than the real effect of forgiveness. Why do you, why do you say that? rather than the real effect of forgiveness. Why do you say that? The reason I use the language of side effects is because I think it can help us keep in view that forgiveness is a moral response to a relational breach. It's about meaning and relational injustice and healing. And at the same time, because it's humans who are engaging the response, it means that psychology, the cognition, the emotion, the behavior,
宽恕的副作用，而不是宽恕的真正效果。为什么你，为什么你这么说？而不是宽恕的真正效果。为什么你这么说？我使用“副作用”这个词的原因是，我认为它可以帮助我们记住，宽恕是对关系破裂的一种道德回应。它关乎意义、关系不公和治愈。与此同时，因为是人类在参与这种回应，这意味着心理、认知、情感、行为
and the physiology is all part of that. But I think that there are other things we could do to simply get lower heart rate or blood pressure or calm cardiovascular systems that have nothing to do with the offense at all that wouldn't necessarily bring about forgiveness. So there's some irony here because I think what I hear you saying is that when we try and exercise forgiveness because we're trying to obtain some kind of mental or physical benefit, not only is that not potentially real forgiveness, but perhaps we don't even get the full mental and physiological benefits of forgiveness. There's some interesting research that if you ask people to try to simply distract themselves rather
和生理都是其中的一部分。但我认为还有其他事情我们可以做，仅仅是为了降低心率或血压，或者平静心血管系统，这与冒犯完全无关，也不一定会带来宽恕。所以这里有一些讽刺意味，因为我想我听到你说的是，当我们试图练习宽恕，因为我们试图获得某种心理或生理上的好处时，这不仅可能不是真正的宽恕，而且也许我们甚至没有得到宽恕的全部心理和生理益处。有一些有趣的研究表明，如果你要求人们尝试仅仅分散自己的注意力，而不是
than trying to re-appraise it in a forgiving way, for example, that later on when they're prompted to relive the offense, it's the people who try to re-appraise it in a forgiving way that experience the blood pressure changes in an enduring way, whereas the people who merely distracted themselves and had a blood pressure benefit in the short term didn't hold onto that. Because there wasn't real engagement with the relational injustice and that moral response. How useful do you think short-term lab experiments that measure physical markers? How do you useful do you think they are?
尝试以宽恕的方式重新评估它，例如，当他们后来被提示重温冒犯时，是那些尝试以宽恕方式重新评估的人体验到了持久的血压变化，而那些仅仅分散了注意力并在短期内获得血压益处的人并没有保持住。因为没有真正参与到关系不公和那种道德回应中。你认为测量生理标记的短期实验室实验有多大用处？你认为它们在
In telling us about the effects of forgiveness in the real world where both harms can sometimes unfold over years, but also forgiveness can sometimes unfold over years or even decades. I think lab experiments have their place, but we shouldn't overstate them either. So what they allow us to do is examine a thin slice and to determine with specificity
告诉我们宽恕在现实世界中的影响方面有多大用处，在现实世界中，伤害有时会持续多年，但宽恕有时也会持续多年甚至几十年。我认为实验室实验有其地位，但我们也不应该夸大它们。所以它们允许我们做的是检查一个薄片，并以特异性确定
the nature of the different kinds of physiological responses that happen. And how long it takes for a particular reappraisal or rumination condition to have its effect. It's so important to make sure that there is research that examines what it's like to see these responses unfurl over longer durations that follows people over, you know, longitudinal designs or even more dyadic sort of interactions.
发生的不同生理反应的性质。以及某种重新评估或反刍条件产生影响需要多长时间。确保有研究检查在更长的时间跨度内观察这些反应会是什么样子，跟踪人们进行纵向设计或更具二元互动的研究是非常重要的。
You've sometimes talked about forgiveness not as a decision but as a process and you've sometimes drawn an analogy between forgiveness and our response to grief. Can you talk about that? The fact that forgiveness might not be sort of a binary, yes, no answer, but much more of a process. Forgiveness so much like grief is an unfolding journey, we have experienced deep hurt because of a loss. And so our emotions as we process this loss unfold over time. And we may adopt a different mindset about it and experience a sense that we are moving forward
你有时谈到宽恕不是一个决定，而是一个过程，你有时在宽恕和我们对悲伤的反应之间画了一个类比。你能谈谈那个吗？宽恕可能不是一种二元的“是/否”答案，而更像是一个过程。宽恕非常像悲伤，是一个展开的旅程，我们因为失去而经历了深刻的伤害。所以当我们处理这种损失时，我们的情绪会随着时间的推移而展开。我们可能会对此采取不同的心态，并体验到一种我们正在前进的感觉，
in our meaning making, in our absorption of the reality of it, in our reckoning with it, and in our capacity to tolerate distress around it. And perhaps even in our sense of hope. And then we can have memories arise and setbacks occur in how in terms of how we we feel. And so there's not like this neat linear process where you do step A and then B and then C and then you're done.
在我们的意义构建中，在我们的现实吸收中，在我们的清算中，以及在我们容忍周围痛苦的能力中。也许甚至在我们的希望感中。然后我们可能会有记忆浮现，在我们的感受方面发生挫折。所以没有那种整洁的线性过程，你做A步，然后B，然后C，然后你就完成了。
This journey has its own twists and turns and there can be surprises. There can be times of incredible, effortful intentionality that feel almost fruitless. But there are other times where that persistence can all of a sudden be met with like an aha revelation, a gift, but those emotions can't just be sort of unfriiled at will. To put this another way, you can decide to forgive someone, but your heart might not go
这段旅程有其曲折，也可能会有惊喜。有时会有令人难以置信的、费力的刻意尝试，却感觉几乎毫无成果。但也有其他时候，那种坚持会突然迎来一种顿悟，一份礼物，但这些情绪不能仅仅随意地展开。换句话说，你可以决定宽恕某人，但你的心可能不会
along with your head. The choice to forgive can be made in an instant, but the experience of what it means to forgive can unfold much more slowly. There are two types of forgiveness that are sometimes discussed and this comes out of the work of Everett Worthington. Decisional forgiveness is this very cognitive sort of intention and commitment to respond in a way that might align with one's values system to sort of do the right thing as it were in forgiving. And there's also emotional forgiveness, which involves a change of heart, where more positive and
随着你的头脑一起。宽恕的选择可以在瞬间做出，但宽恕意味着什么的体验可以展开得慢得多。有两种类型的宽恕有时会被讨论，这来自于埃弗雷特·沃辛顿的工作。决策性宽恕是一种非常认知的意图和承诺，以一种可能与个人价值观体系一致的方式做出回应，即在宽恕中做正确的事。还有情感宽恕，它涉及内心的改变，其中更积极和
generous kinds of responses to another human supplant, the hurt in bitter kinds of responses that are otherwise there with unforgiveness. In the work that we're doing, we're actually asking people to try on these different mindsets, so they can try this conscious, effortful way of thinking through things. What we find is that that too has at least a short term, reliable effect on shifting people's emotions, not only de-escalating the negative intensity, but also generating positive, other-oriented responses. Charlotte says our ability to demonstrate positive and generous responses to another person, to empathize with them, this is critical to our ability to forgive.
慷慨的对他人回应取代了原本存在的伤害和痛苦的反应。在我们所做的工作中，我们实际上是在要求人们尝试这些不同的心态，这样他们就可以尝试这种有意识的、费力的思考方式。我们发现，这至少在短期内对改变人们的情绪有可靠的效果，不仅降低了负面强度，还产生了积极的、以他人为导向的反应。夏洛特说，我们向他人展示积极和慷慨反应的能力，去同情他们的能力，这对我们宽恕的能力至关重要。
An empathy seems to come more easily to some of us than to others. Charlottes and her colleagues have tried to unravel why that is. They've studied the effects of genes, and they've also looked at gender differences in terms of empathy and forgiveness. Empathy plays such a central role in forgiveness when in self-report higher perspective taking an empathic concern than men do. What we've found in our research is that empathy is the connector. It's the mediator between gender and the disposition of forgivingness in general, as well as the extent to which
而同理心似乎对我们中的一些人来说比对其他人更容易。夏洛特和她的同事们试图解开为什么会这样。他们研究了基因的影响，也观察了性别在同理心和宽恕方面的差异。同理心在宽恕中扮演着如此核心的角色，在自我报告中，女性比男性有更高的视角采择和同理心关注。我们在研究中发现，同理心是连接器。它是性别与一般宽恕倾向之间的中介，以及
people express forgiveness toward a real life offender while they're reliving that hurt. We also did some genetics research looking at a particular genetic variation that is associated with empathy and sociality. So the oxytocin receptor gene single nucleotide polymorphism RS53576 was the predictor. So empathy is the hub of the genetics and forgiveness relationship. We've talked at some length Charlotte about the effects that forgiveness can have on us. And I want to spend a moment just talking about the effects that forgiveness can have on other people, including people who have transgressed against us.
人们在重温伤害时对现实生活中的冒犯者表达宽恕的程度。我们还做了一些遗传学研究，观察了一种与同理心和社会性相关的特定基因变异。所以催产素受体基因单核苷酸多态性RS53576是预测因子。所以同理心是遗传学和宽恕关系的枢纽。夏洛特，我们已经详细讨论了宽恕对我们产生的影响。我想花点时间谈谈宽恕对其他人产生的影响，包括那些冒犯过我们的人。
Some years ago, the social psychologist Roy Baumeister conducted a study that found that people were less likely to repeat offenses if they had been forgiven for an earlier offense. What do you make of a study like that? Why do you think you would see an effect like that? Gratitude. When we receive a gift like that, a gift like that, we're grateful for it. And to the extent that people feel appreciative of receiving forgiveness and to the extent that they sense their own accountability for what they have done and they realize the gift that someone's giving them when they're forgiven, they may have a stronger sense of commitment to not enact that sort of harm again. However, it's also the case that when people who have disagreeable personalities receive forgiveness, unfortunately, they sometimes are reinforced.
几年前，社会心理学家罗伊·鲍迈斯特进行了一项研究，发现如果人们因为早期的冒犯而被宽恕，他们就不太可能重复冒犯。你对这样的研究怎么看？你认为为什么会看到这样的效果？感激。当我们收到那样的礼物时，那样的礼物，我们对此心存感激。在人们感到感激收到宽恕的程度上，以及在他们意识到自己对所做之事负有责任，并意识到当他们被宽恕时别人给予他们的礼物时，他们可能会有更强的承诺感，不再再次实施那种伤害。然而，当具有令人不快人格的人收到宽恕时，不幸的是，他们有时会受到强化。
They're almost emboldened, and they have a sense that they can get away with things. So I think that can go in two different ways. I'm wondering Charlotte as somebody who is besides a researcher and a clinical expert, somebody who's also a human being who goes through life, have there been times in your life when you have experienced hurts that you find difficult to set aside or forget? Oh yes I have and what's so interesting to me is that sometimes it's hard to not ruminate even about small things, but more often for me, rumination has been a struggle for the really, really deep losses and wounds,
他们几乎变得胆大妄为，他们有一种可以逃脱惩罚的感觉。所以我认为这可以朝两个不同的方向发展。夏洛特，作为一名除了研究员和临床专家之外，也是一个经历生活的人，我很好奇，你生命中有没有经历过你觉得难以放下或忘记的伤害？哦，是的，我有，对我来说最有趣的是，有时即使是小事也很难不反刍，但对我来说，反刍更多时候是针对那些非常、非常深刻的损失和伤口，
ones that are related to the suffering and death of people I love dearly. I love dearly. You know, the hurts that are the hardest for me are the ones where it's so clear to me what the wrongdoing is and the consequences are so enormous and there's no one doing them. In some ways, I think, Charlotte, you're pointing to something that a lot of people experience, which is sometimes we are called to exercise forgiveness when a transgressor has not acknowledged the harm they have done to us. So in some ways, you don't have the satisfaction of having achieved justice. And what I hear you saying is that these are the things that you have struggled with where in these situations you have asked yourself,
那些与我深爱的人的痛苦和死亡有关的伤口。我深爱的人。你知道，对我来说最难的伤害是那些我非常清楚错误是什么，后果非常巨大，而且没有人承担责任的伤害。在某种程度上，我认为，夏洛特，你指出了很多人经历的事情，那就是有时当冒犯者没有承认他们对我们造成的伤害时，我们被要求练习宽恕。所以从某种意义上说，你没有获得实现正义的满足感。我听到你说的是，这些是你挣扎过的事情，在这些情况下，你问过自己，
am I still capable of trying to exercise forgiveness when in fact there has been incomplete accountability and perhaps never will be complete accountability? Yes, it is definitely the hardest when an injustice is deeply painful and so clearly wrong and yet goes unrecognized by the person who bears responsibility, especially when it's not just sort of a mere matter of opinion or perspective or personal preference for how something is done, but it's an undeniable sort of offense where there's no apology on the horizon. There is no indication of regard at all. That's the hardest because it feels so dehumanizing, feels so
当事实上问责不完整，而且可能永远不会有完全的问责时，我是否仍然有能力尝试练习宽恕？是的，当不公正极其痛苦且显然是错误，但却被负有责任的人忽视时，这绝对是最难的，特别是当它不仅仅是关于意见、观点或个人偏好的问题，而是一种不可否认的冒犯，且没有任何道歉的迹象时。根本没有任何尊重的迹象。这是最难的，因为它感觉如此非人性化，感觉如此
unacknowledged and in some ways than so unspeakable. Those are really really hard situations. That's where having a very long view and a view of justice that transcends what any one of us is capable of in this world can be very important that to the extent that there's a sense of ultimate trust, for example, in a God who cares about justice and transformation and mercy. That can be incredibly powerful. Now, your father was a pastor and I understand that you yourself are also deeply religious. And I'm wondering has that informed the way that you are thinking about forgiveness?
未被承认，在某种程度上是不可言说的。那些真的是非常困难的情况。这就是为什么拥有一个非常长远的眼光，以及一个超越我们这个世界上任何人能力的公正观是非常重要的，即在某种程度上有一种终极的信任，例如，对一个关心正义、转变和怜悯的上帝的信任。那可能是极其强大的。现在，你的父亲是一位牧师，我理解你自己也深信宗教。我想知道这是否影响了你思考宽恕的方式？
Because I hear very much, as you just said, it may be that in the here and now, there's not a neat equation that basically says, I'm going to give you X amount of forgiveness in return for Y amount of accountability. It may be that one of those is actually not in the here and now, but in the here after, at least as you see it. You're right. My father was a pastor who was present with people in the best of times and also the worst of times, the horrific sort of traumatic times, the betrayals offering care. And so I think I became very aware about the kinds of suffering that so very many people experience. And yet it's so rare that apologies and repentant change and accountability are fully
因为我听到了很多，正如你刚才所说，可能在此时此地，没有一个整洁的等式，基本上说，我将给你X量的宽恕以换取Y量的问责。可能其中之一实际上不在此时此地，而是在来世，至少在你看来是这样。你是对的。我的父亲是一位牧师，他在最好的时候和最坏的时候，那些可怕的创伤时期，背叛时期，提供关怀，与人们在一起。所以我认为我变得非常意识到如此多的人所经历的痛苦。然而，道歉、悔改的改变和问责在此时此地以令人信服和完整的方式体现出来的情况是如此罕见。
embodied in convincing and complete sorts of ways here and now. So yes, I've been shaped by that and certainly have been shaped by a gospel that takes very seriously injustice and the cause of the oppressed and the importance of having justice and mercy. Meet in God who took on the fullness of pain and suffering and is the one through whom all of that will be transformed. Where every tool that is a weapon of harm will be transformed into a tool of cultivation. One ten thousand feet, Emmanuel AME Church. On June 17, 2015, a white supremacist walked into the Emmanuel African Methodist Episcopal Church in Charleston, South Carolina.
所以是的，我受到了那样的塑造，当然也受到了一个非常认真对待不公正、被压迫者的事业以及拥有正义和怜悯重要性的福音的塑造。在上帝那里相遇，他承担了痛苦和苦难的全部，他是所有这一切将通过他得到转变的那一位。在那里，每一个作为伤害武器的工具都将转变为耕耘的工具。一万英尺，伊曼纽尔非裔卫理公会教堂。2015年6月17日，一名白人至上主义者走进南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的伊曼纽尔非裔卫理公会教堂。
African Methodist Episcopal Church in Charleston, South Carolina. What happened next shocked the nation, and a warning that it remains shocking years later. The man had a gun, and he used it to murder nine black people inside the church. People inside were gathered for Bible study. These people were in church. They were in church. And they violated the sanctity of that. Investigators are calling the shooting a hate crime. The only reason someone can walk into church and shoot people, pray, is out of hate, the only reason.
南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的非裔卫理公会教堂。接下来发生的事情震惊了全国，并且警告说，多年后它仍然令人震惊。那个人有一把枪，他用它在教堂内谋杀了九名黑人。里面的人聚集在一起进行圣经学习。这些人是在教堂里。他们在教堂里。他们亵渎了那里的神圣。调查人员称这次枪击事件为仇恨犯罪。一个人走进教堂射杀祈祷的人的唯一原因，就是出于仇恨，唯一的理由。
The shooter was later convicted on federal hate crime charges and sentenced to death. Here's what the sister of one of the victims had to say to him. For me, I'm a work in progress, and I acknowledge that I am very angry. But one thing to pay to always join in and our family with is that she taught me that we are the family that love built. We have no room for hate. So we have to forgive and I pray God on your soul. What goes through your mind as you hear this, Charlotte?
枪手后来被判联邦仇恨犯罪罪名成立，并被判处死刑。这是其中一名受害者的姐妹对他所说的话。对我来说，我是一个正在进行中的作品，我承认我非常生气。但有一件事要始终加入，在我们的家庭中，她教导我，我们是爱建立的家庭。我们没有仇恨的空间。所以我们必须宽恕，我祈求上帝保佑你的灵魂。当你听到这些时，夏洛特，你脑子里在想什么？
I hear such profound faith, such profound commitment to a life and an intergenerational community, it's mother-manual that lives a gospel of grace and forgiveness, and that acknowledges the horror and the injustice of the horrific murder and that is so able to tell the full truth that this particular clip, this woman can speak to her grief, her anger, to the wrongness of the injustice and can also say that there is no room for heat that seeks to destroy but rather seeks to Zee Green, how sweet the sound, that's safe, I want to talk for a moment, Charlotte, about not just interpersonal harms and interpersonal forgiveness, but harms that take place at the level of groups, perhaps even historical harms, and our capacity to forgive entire groups or the demands that are placed on some groups to forgive other groups. Does the research say anything at all about the value of doing so, the challenges of doing so, and the benefits of doing so? What strikes me first is to hear the experience of people who have experienced profound injustice
我听到了如此深刻的信仰，如此深刻地致力于一种生活和一个代际社区，它是母亲伊曼纽尔，它践行着恩典和宽恕的福音，它承认了可怕谋杀的恐怖和不公正，并且如此能够说出全部真相，这个特定的片段，这个女人可以谈论她的悲伤、她的愤怒、不公正的错误，也可以说没有空间容纳寻求毁灭的仇恨，而是寻求……多么甜美的声音，那是安全的，我想谈谈，夏洛特，不仅仅是人际伤害和人际宽恕，还有发生在群体层面的伤害，也许甚至是历史伤害，以及我们宽恕整个群体的能力，或者对某些群体提出的宽恕其他群体的要求。研究是否说了任何关于这样做的价值、这样做的挑战以及这样做的益处？首先打动我的是听到那些经历过深刻不公正的人的经历，
and to honor those stories and the layers of harm and the implications of those. And to a no way excuse, ignore or distract ourselves from that, but to be able to see the fullness of the wrong. And that condemnation alone may not bring about the change that people seek, so it's an invitation to accountability. And my first thought is how important it is for us to focus on the need to repent. That is to recognize the places where we are the complicit ones, where we are the bystanders.
并尊重那些故事以及伤害的层次和影响。并且绝不找借口、忽视或分散我们对这些的注意力，而是能够看到错误的全部。仅仅谴责可能无法带来人们寻求的改变，所以这是一个对问责的邀请。我的第一个想法是，我们关注悔改的必要性是多么重要。也就是说，要认识到我们是共犯的地方，我们是旁观者的地方。
Part of this field of forgiveness research examines what it means to reckon with our own wrongdoing and our own participation in systemic wrongs and to enact the kind of change that halts the harm, creates safety and fairness because we actually need to also engage in the kind of change that's required for our victims to receive the good change that they seek. And that is good for us too. When we come back, when forgiveness to you feels like betrayal to me. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. How long do you carry around your grudges and wounds? Do you nurture them, grow them, tend to them? What effect does this have on you?
宽恕研究领域的这一部分检查了面对我们自己的不当行为和我们自己对系统性错误的参与意味着什么，并制定那种制止伤害、创造安全和公平的改变，因为我们实际上也需要参与受害者寻求获得良好改变所需的改变。这对我们也有好处。稍后回来，当宽恕对你来说感觉像是对我的背叛。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你背负怨恨和伤口有多久了？你滋养它们、培育它们、照料它们吗？这对你有什么影响？
At Hope College in Michigan, psychologist Charlotte Whitfleet studies the psychological barriers to forgiveness and the consequences of letting go of our hurts. Charlotte, I want to play you a clip. This is from the writer Amber Sparks discussing her book and I do not forgive you. That's the title of the book. She is referring here in this discussion to the Me Too movement and the harms inflicted on women for many centuries.
在密歇根州的霍普学院，心理学家夏洛特·威特弗利特研究了宽恕的心理障碍以及放下伤害的后果。夏洛特，我想播放一段片段。这是作家安布尔·斯帕克斯讨论她的书《我没有原谅你》。那是书名。她在这次讨论中指的是“我也是”运动以及许多世纪以来对女性造成的伤害。
It was important to me to sort of write an anti-redemption story because we have this idea about narrative in our society where there's somebody and they do something bad to someone else and eventually they're forgiven and everybody learns something and then we can tie a bow on it. It isn't that great. And I felt like with what's happening right now, you know, with me too, there are people who don't deserve redemption or at least it's not owed to you as a victim to give somebody that gift, especially after like a freaking year or two or whatever, which some of these guys are asking for. So it was important to me to sort of write a counter narrative that included the idea that the person
对我来说，写一个反救赎故事很重要，因为我们在社会中对叙事有这种想法，即有人对别人做了坏事，最终他们被宽恕了，每个人都学到了一些东西，然后我们可以打个结。这并不那么好。我觉得随着现在正在发生的事情，你知道，随着“我也是”，有些人不值得救赎，或者至少作为受害者，你没有义务给某人那份礼物，特别是在像该死的一年或两年或无论什么之后，其中一些家伙正在要求的那样。所以对我来说，写一个包含以下想法的反叙事很重要：那个人
doesn't have to grant forgiveness, and that not only cannot be okay, but that can actually be transformative. I'm wondering in the course of the Mito movement, there have been cases where people have said the people who have harassed women have lost their jobs or they've suffered in some way, they've been punished enough, they should be forgiven and we should move on. And I'm wondering both as a researcher who studies forgiveness and as a woman, how you hear
不必给予宽恕，这不仅可以没关系，而且实际上可以是变革性的。我很好奇，在“我也是”运动的过程中，有一些案例，人们说骚扰女性的人已经失去了工作，或者他们以某种方式受苦了，他们已经受到了足够的惩罚，他们应该被宽恕，我们应该继续前进。我很好奇，作为一名研究宽恕的研究员，也作为一名女性，你是怎么听到的
that kind of conversation, how does that strike you? I think there's something about empathizing primarily with the wrong doer at the expense of the victim that is so problematic and that telling the truth about what has happened needs to place at the center the concerns of the person who has been most violated, most unjustly treated, the group that has been most hurt or unjustly treated. But it is an additional injustice to quickly rush to say, oh, I'm so moved by that powerful display of repentance, and then forget that true repentance involves accountable change and the welcoming of being accountable.
那种对话，你有什么感想？我认为，主要站在加害者一边而牺牲受害者利益去共情，这是非常有问题的。讲述所发生之事的真相时，必须将那些最受伤害、最受不公正对待的人或群体的关切放在核心位置。如果匆忙地表示“哦，我被那场强有力的忏悔表演感动了”，却忘记了真正的忏悔包含负责任的改变和乐于承担责任，那将是另一种不公正。
So I think we need to be looking for that. We need to be looking for are the people who are being held accountable, owning their own need for undergoing change. That's genuine and that's responsive. I want to draw your attention to something that Ambers Park said in that clip, because at least emotionally, I feel like it rings true. It seems to me that sometimes not forgiving can feel empowering. Not forgiving can feel empowering because it can be an agentic choice in contrast to being put in a position that you didn't have any choice about. One thing that we found in my very first study of forgiveness comparing
所以我认为我们需要寻找这一点。我们需要观察那些被要求负责的人，是否在主动承担自己需要改变的需求。那是真诚且有回应的。我想请大家注意安伯斯·帕克在片段中所说的话，因为至少在情感上，我觉得它听起来很真实。在我看来，有时不原谅会让人感到更有力量。不原谅可以是一种自主的选择，与被迫处于某种别无选择的境地形成对比。我在第一次关于宽恕的研究中发现，比较
rumination about a hurt to grudge holding was that when nursing a grudge against a real life offender, people felt more control. They felt less sad. They felt less afraid. They felt more positive. At the same time is also true that the ones that remember the humanity of the offender, and that engaged a forgiving response, those empathic and forgiving responses, were even more full of perceived control and positivity,
对伤害的反复咀嚼与怀恨在心时，人们在对现实中的加害者怀恨时，会感到更多的掌控感。他们感到不那么悲伤，不那么恐惧，也更积极。同时，那些记得加害者人性并采取宽恕回应的人，那些充满共情和宽恕的回应，实际上拥有更多的掌控感和积极性，
with less anger and less sadness. And that's where the embodied stress responses were quieted down the most. I'm thinking about our capacity for anger and our capacity for forgiveness. In terms of our evolutionary history and I wanna run an idea by you, it seems to me that if forgiveness was always in our interest
伴随着更少的愤怒和更少的悲伤。这就是身体压力反应得到最大程度缓解的地方。我在思考我们对愤怒和宽恕的能力。从我们的进化史来看，我想和你探讨一个观点：如果宽恕总是符合我们的利益，
or in the interest of our groups, we wouldn't find it so hard to do. Our brains would find it easier to forget grudges if in fact forgetting grudges was good for us or at least evolutionarily if it had been good for our ancestors. I'm wondering if it's possible that the story or forgiveness is it possible that it's missing out
或者符合我们群体的利益，我们就不会觉得它那么难做到了。如果忘记怨恨确实对我们有益，或者至少从进化角度看对我们的祖先有益，我们的大脑会更容易忘记怨恨。我在想，关于宽恕的故事，是否可能遗漏了
on the power that, you know, retribution and vengeance have to generate good behavior? In other words, if I thought you were certain to forgive me no matter what I did, so long as I'm, you know, appropriately contrite afterwards, isn't that an invitation for me to take advantage of you? You are right in Mike McCullough's area. Groups try to uphold their social norms in lots of different ways. And punishment is one way, sometimes retaliation,
报复和惩罚在产生良好行为方面的力量？换句话说，如果我认为无论我做什么，只要事后表现得足够悔恨，你肯定会原谅我，那这难道不是在邀请我占你便宜吗？你正好说到了迈克·麦卡洛的领域。群体试图通过多种方式维护社会规范。惩罚是一种方式，有时是报复，
sometimes avoidance or ostracism, is enacted as a way of not only addressing the harm directly or the wrong do or directly, but also sending a powerful signal about what the rules are. So everybody observing is pretty clear on what it means to be in this group. And, you know, Mike McCulloch's work also identifies a place MacKullis' work also identifies a place for forgiveness and conciliatory responses for the good of the group and the survival of it. I mean, this is the paradox, isn't it, which is that on a group that basically has no memory of past wrongs and ignores those past wrongs or is too quick to forgive is a group
有时是回避或排斥，这不仅是为了直接处理伤害或加害者，也是为了发出关于规则是什么的强烈信号。这样，所有观察者都能清楚在这个群体中意味着什么。而且，迈克·麦卡洛的研究也指出了宽恕和和解回应在群体利益和生存方面的作用。我的意思是，这就是悖论，不是吗？一个基本上没有过去错误记忆、忽视这些错误或太快原谅的群体，
that's going to get taken advantage of, but a group that cannot forget past wrongs or cannot get beyond the pain of wrongs that have been done to them is not a group that can move forward. In some ways, it's sort of your stuck between a rock and a heart place. It's really the path, the middle path that you suggested where you're both aware of the harms that were done and your exercising empathy for the people who've harmed you. I mean, that does seem to be the middle path between these two extremes. I think you're right. It's so crucial to be able to engage in the both end of truth telling and accountability. So we need to reckon with wrongs. We need to resist
是一个会被占便宜的群体；但一个无法忘记过去错误或无法走出所受伤害痛苦的群体，也不是一个能向前迈进的群体。在某种程度上，你就像被夹在两难境地中。这确实是你建议的中间道路，既意识到所受的伤害，又对伤害你的人行使共情。这似乎确实是这两个极端之间的中间道路。我想你是对的。能够同时做到讲述真相和承担责任至关重要。我们需要正视错误。我们需要抵制
minimizing them or excusing or ignoring or simply distracting ourselves from them because that can reward bad behavior, especially by disagreeable personalities who feel emboldened by that. personalities who feel emboldened by that. And at the same time, when vindication is pursued predominantly through vindictiveness, that is a very destructive pattern too. And so if a group wants to move forward or if a person wants to move forward, they have to be sure that they can see that humanity,
淡化、找借口、忽视或仅仅转移注意力，因为这可能会奖励不良行为，尤其是那些被这种行为壮胆的讨人厌的人格。同时，当通过报复来追求平反时，那也是一种非常破坏性的模式。因此，如果一个群体或一个人想要向前迈进，他们必须确保能够看到人性，
and they can see the kind of corrective change that needs to be enacted so that those past wrongs don't simply get perpetuated into the future. You've talked Charlotte about how, in some ways, when it comes to forgiving other people, it's this balance between seeking accountability and exercising empathy. How does this balance play out when it comes to forgiving ourselves for things that we have said or done? One thing that's really powerful is how important it is to humbly reckon with our own capacity for wrongdoing and to address the reality of hurts that we have caused others by behaving in ways that are unfair or unjust. But at the same time, to be understanding and patient with ourselves, even as we are persistent and intentional in trying to do the right thing in our relationship with others. It's just so crucial to have the accountability piece there, though, because otherwise I think we can slip into sort of a cheap grace that so readily, you know, sees all the reasons why we should be excused of the things we've done, but finds it so hard to extend mercy to others. So it's a complicated
并且能够看到需要采取的纠正性改变，这样过去的错误就不会在未来简单地延续。夏洛特，你谈到在宽恕他人时，这在寻求责任和行使共情之间是一种平衡。当涉及到原谅我们自己所说或所做的事情时，这种平衡是如何体现的？非常有力的一点是，谦卑地正视我们自己犯错的能力，并解决我们因不公平或不公正行为而给他人造成的伤害，这一点非常重要。但同时，即使我们在努力与他人建立正确关系时保持坚持和有意图，也要对自己保持理解和耐心。然而，拥有责任感的部分至关重要，否则我认为我们可能会陷入一种廉价的恩典，很容易看到所有我们应该被原谅的理由，却发现很难向他人施予仁慈。所以，要达到正确的平衡是一件
thing to get the right mix. I want to play your clip from the movie Paid Forward. Helen Hans character is a single mother and recovering alcoholic and she's speaking to her mother about being traumatized during her childhood. Take a listen to the clip. I want to try to do something. All the things when I was a kid, When I was a kid, the booze and the men, what happened to me when you weren't looking? I know we're all weak. Not you. No, I've been weak.
复杂的事情。我想播放一段电影《让爱传出去》的片段。海伦·亨特的角色是一位单身母亲和康复中的酗酒者，她正在和母亲谈论童年时期受到的创伤。听听这段片段。我想试着做点什么。所有那些事，当我还是个孩子的时候，当我还是个孩子的时候，酒精和男人，当你没注意时发生在我身上的事。我知道我们都很软弱。不是你。不，我很软弱。
Well, here's the thing. I forgive you. I want to speak a moment, Charlotte, about why many of us find these moments moving, even when we are not involved, when we are not the protagonist, why is it that we find the granting of forgiveness to be beautiful? It's so striking. When we have a sense that someone has seen it,
好吧，事情是这样的。我原谅你。夏洛特，我想谈谈为什么我们许多人会发现这些时刻令人感动，即使我们没有参与其中，即使我们不是主角，为什么我们会觉得给予宽恕是美丽的？这太引人注目了。当我们感觉到有人看到了它，
they can tell the truth about it, and they have suffered. There's just a very, very powerful awareness of the reaching across that injustice gap to extend some sort of kindness, a mercy to someone that takes our It is remarkable when we witness these profound, generous gifts of forgiveness. And I think it inspires hope for us too. I am borrowing this from Everett Worthington, but you know he is quick to say and I join with this perspective that forgiving is about giving, but in giving there's receiving too. Charlotte Whitfley is a psychologist at Hope College in Michigan. Charlotte
他们能说出真相，并且他们受过苦。这是一种非常、非常强大的意识，跨越那道不公正的鸿沟，向某人施予某种善意和仁慈，这触动了我们的……当我们见证这些深刻、慷慨的宽恕礼物时，它是非凡的。我认为这也激发了我们的希望。我借用了埃弗雷特·沃辛顿的话，但他很快就会说，我也赞同这个观点，即宽恕是关于给予，但在给予中也有收获。夏洛特·惠特利是密歇根州霍普学院的心理学家。夏洛特，
thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me on Hidden Brain. It's a joy. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Turner Canty.
感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我参加《隐藏的大脑》。这是一种荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是特纳·坎蒂。
Turner is a freelance producer who's been helping us with an audio project that was on our to-do list for months. It was one of those projects that required attention to detail and patience, both of which Turner brought to his work in abundance. We are really grateful for your help Turner and wish you the best of luck as you get ready to begin graduate school. If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with three friends. If they are new
特纳是一位自由职业制片人，他一直在帮助我们完成一个已经在我们的待办事项清单上挂了几个月的音频项目。这是那些需要注重细节和耐心的项目之一，特纳在工作中充分展现了这两点。我们非常感谢你的帮助，特纳，并祝你在准备开始研究生学习时一切顺利。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必分享给三位朋友。如果他们是
to podcasting, please show them how to subscribe to our show. Next week, why it's so hard to apologize or to admit when we've hurt someone? I'm Shankar Vedantin, see you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客新手，请教他们如何订阅我们的节目。下周，为什么道歉或承认伤害了别人那么难？我是尚卡尔·维丹坦，下周见。